cela fait deux ans que cassandra et
claudia se connaissent copine dans la
vie copines aussi quand il s'agit de
mettre les baskets
elles sont venues ensemble et envisage
de pratiquer une activité sportive cette
année j'en avais fait l'année dernière
et j'avais arrêté du coup bah je
reprends pas envie de reprendre
quel type de sport la gym la danse et
puis le voilà
ouais la gym et la danse
aérobic step plus 250 jeunes filles
licenciées depuis plusieurs années ou
novices tout sur le même tempo
j'aime bien le sport ça défoule et je
dépense de l'énergie
ici elle découvre certaines des
activités qui sont proposées par les
associations sportives de leur
établissement dans le district de
montargis même la musculation il
n'allait pas leur dire que ce n'est pas
fait pour elle bah oui pour les filles
et aussi pourquoi pas c'est pas que pour
les garçons que on essaye un peu tout
c'est bien parce que dieu
non ce n'est que quand y'a les garçons
et puis c'est plus motivant d'être avec
les copies les de faire tous en groupe
o'shea promouvoir le sport scolaire au
féminin un axe fort de la fédération du
loiret avec l'objectif de faire tomber
certaines barrières
ça fait trois quatre ans qu'on développe
ont fait cette journée et on arrive à
avoir des taux de licenciés autour de
41% qui est au dessus du niveau national
donc depuis trois quatre ans on a vu ce
taux augmente et orages peut-être pas
arriver à la parité un jour mais en tout
cas on essaie de temps de renverser dans
le département du loiret plus de dix
mille jeunes filles et garçons sont
licenciés à lui et naissance